>> Jesse: BREAKING NEWS.
THE SUPREME COURT TEMPORARILY
BAILING JOE BIDEN OUT AND
POSSIBLY POSTPONING A HUGE
CATASTROPHE AT THE BORDER.
MOM'S AGO, BLOCKING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FROM ENDING
TITLE 42 WHICH IS EXPECTED TO
LAPSE IN TWO DAYS.
FORCED TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AS ILLEGALS FLOOD INTO
THE CITY.
VIDEO SHOWS EXTREME OVERCROWDING
AT A MIGRANT PROCESSING CENTER.
500 PEOPLE ARE PACKED INTO A POT
OF THAT WAS ONLY MEANT TO HOLD
100, AND THERE'S ONLY ONE
BATHROOM.
THOSE ARE JUST THE LUCKY ONES.
OUTSIDE, DOZENS OF MIGRANTS
SLEEPING ON THE STREETS AND
FREEZING TEMPS.
RIGHT NOW, BORDER PATROL IS
OVERWHELMED WITH A FEW THOUSAND
DAILY CROSSINGS.
RIGHT ON CUE, BIDEN MEDIA
CHEERLEADERS SAY THAT IT IS ALL
THE REPUBLICANS FAULT.
SO, DANA PERINO, JOE GETS BAILED
OUT BY THE SUPREME COURT.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THAT?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO GET BAILED
OUT IN THE END, AND I THINK
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CONFUSION ON
THIS.
TITLE 42 IS JUST ONE OF THE
TOOLS THAT THEY CAN USE IN ORDER
TO TELL MIGRANTS, NO, YOU HAVE
TO TURN BACK HERE THAT WAS
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
HERE IS ANOTHER THING WE CAN DO
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE DON'T COME
IN WHO MIGHT HAVE CORONAVIRUS.
THOSE WERE THE EARLY DAYS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO USE THAT TO TRY TO
GET THE NUMBERS DOWN AT THE
BORDER.
HOWEVER, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ALSO WANTED TO DO
THE OPPOSITE OF ANYTHING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID ON
IMMIGRATION.
THE STATES WERE SAYING NOW, THIS
IS ACTUALLY WORKING.
YOU SHOULD NOT WANT TO END IT.
NOW THE COURTS HAVE SAID OKAY,
FINE.
THE STATES TODAY FILED A CASE --
AN APPEAL TO THE SUPREME COURT
AND SAID PLEASE DON'T LET THE
WHITE HOUSE DO THIS.
ALL THAT HAPPENED TODAY, THE
SUPREME COURT SAID WE ARE GOING
TO GIVE ANOTHER 24 HOURS FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE TO REPLY TO THIS
EMERGENCY REQUEST, AND THEN WE
WILL SEE IF THEY ARGUE AND ON
MERIT.
IT IS NOT COMPLETELY DEAD.
THIS DOES NOT ACTUALLY END UNTIL
MIDNIGHT ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT, SO
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
REPRIEVE.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WILL DO.
IF THEY ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR POSITION OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS, KATIE CAN CORRECT ME IF I
AM WRONG BECAUSE SHE KNOWS THIS
ISSUE BETTER THAN ANYONE.
>> Harold: LET'S SEE WHAT THE
MEDIA IS DOING.
GREG, TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> Greg: I SHALL.
>> WE TALK ABOUT OPEN BORDERS.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE EVER HEARD
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAY "WE HAVE AN
OPEN BORDER.
COME ON OVER HERE" THE PEOPLE I
HAVE HEARD SAY ARE YOU, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, RON DeSANTIS.
>> IT WAS KNOWN FROM THE TIME HE
GOT ELECTED THAT JOE BIDEN
SUPPORTED OPEN BORDERS.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE GOING TO
ENFORCE THE IMMIGRATION LAWS ARE
NOT IS KNOWN ACROSS THE WORLD,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, KNOWN
AMONG THE CARTEL.
>> Jesse: GRAY, HAVE YOU EVER
SEEN VIDEOS OF THIS?
>> Greg: THANK YOU,
GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
IT IS SO INTERESTING WHEN YOU DO
SEE PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA.
YOU CAN TELL EXACTLY WHAT THEY
READ, WHAT THEY DON'T READ.
SHE HAS NO CLUE WHAT'S GOING ON.
THERE IS SO MUCH DOCUMENTATION
OF WHAT'S GOING ON, AND SHE'S IN
HER OWN LITTLE BUBBLE.
I CANNOT WAIT FOR THIS RESPONSE.
YOU LIKE THAT, IN AMERICA?
YOU CAN HAVE THAT.
EVEN HAROLD LAUGHED AT IT.
YOU SHOULD NOT.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW -- I THINK
IT WAS -- KATIE, WHAT IS THE
POLICY?
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE MEDIA IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY FEEL ABOUT
THE BORDER SITUATION BECAUSE DO
THEY ACTUALLY KNOW HOW THEY
FEEL, OR DO THEY ONLY WAIT UNTIL
THE OTHER SIDE SAYS SOMETHING.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF ONE SIDE SAYS
THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE, THEY
WILL SAY NO, IT IS SECURE.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU SHOW THEM THAT
IT ISN'T, THEY WILL SAY THAT'S
GOOD BECAUSE WE NEED MORE
WORKERS.
WE ARE NOT PUMPING OUT THE KIDS.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE
COME HERE, SO WHAT IS IT GOING
TO BE?
IS THE BORDER SECURE?
OR IF IT'S NOT, IT'S A BAD
THING.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WITH
INFLATION.
IT WAS LIKE THERE IS NO
INFLATION, THEN WE SHOW THAT
THERE IS, THEY SAY INFLATION IS
GOOD.
THE TENDENCY IS TO DENY THE BAD
NEWS OR SHIFT THE BLAME TO
SOMEBODY ELSE, AND THEN WHEN YOU
PRESENT THEM WITH IRREFUTABLE
EVIDENCE, THEY SAY YES, IT IS
GREAT.
I THINK THE PROBLEM DOES NOT
EXIST, OR IT DOES, AND YOU LOVE
IT.
YOU CANNOT HAVE BOTH.
>> Greg: DID SHE ACTUALLY GO
TO THE BORDER?
>> Katie: I AM NOT SURE, MAYBE
SHE DID GO TO THE BORDER.
I WILL NOT SPECULATE.
BUT I DO FIND IT INTERESTING
THAT NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE
MEDIA IS INTERESTED IN THE
STORY.
WE HAVE BEEN COVERING THIS FOR
YEARS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS CATASTROPHE
AND THIS NEW CRISIS, AT EVERY
LEVEL THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN
BEFORE.
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PERSPECTIVE, ARGUING TODAY IN
THE BRIEFING THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS DOING LOTS OF
THINGS.
WE INVEST FOR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN NEW RESOURCES, AND
REPUBLICANS DO NOT WANT TO DO
IT.
THEY ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM,
HELPING THE TRAFFICKERS.
A BILLION DOLLARS IS WORTHLESS
IF YOU ARE CONTINUING TO MANAGE
THE PROBLEM WHICH THEY ARE DOING
BY OPENING UP NEW PROCESSING
FACILITIES.
IT IS LIKE HAVING A LEAK IN YOUR
ROOF AND PUTTING OUT A BUCKET.
YOU JUST MOVE THE BUCKET, PUT
ANOTHER BUCKET IN.
YOU KEEP DOING THAT, AND YOU
HAVE THIS CRISIS WHERE YOU
CANNOT FIX IT, AND UNTIL THE
WHITE HOUSE CALLS FOR CONGRESS
TO PASS SOME KIND OF A SILENT
REFORM BECAUSE THAT IS THE
REASON YOU ARE SEEING THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE,
INCLUDING 84,000 PEOPLE IN THE
PAST FOUR MONTHS, DROPPED OFF IN
EL PASO, RUN BY A DEMOCRATIC
MAYOR.
YOU HAVE THE NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR, SAYING WE CANNOT SUSTAIN
THIS WITH ALL THESE PEOPLE
COMING.
THAT IS MORE PEOPLE THEN MY
HOMETOWN AND FOUR MONTHS COMING
IN.
>> Greg: KATIE, CAN I READ A
HEADLINE FOR YOU?
SHE COMPARES HUMAN BEINGS TO
RAINWATER.
>> Katie: IT IS JUST --
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT HOW THE
MEDIA COVERS IT.
THEY QUESTION YOUR HUMANITY.
>> Katie: STUFFING PEOPLE INTO
BUCKETS AND ALL KINDS OF STUFF.
>> Greg: WHERE IS AOC, HAROLD?
WHY ISN'T SHE IN NO WAY PENSIVE
PRAYING SOMEWHERE?
>> Harold: WE HAVE --
PRESIDENT TRUMP USED AND 2020.
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH -- YOU CAN
REALLY USE IT TO HELP
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT HAD NOT BEEN USED SINCE 1929
WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO KEEP A
CERTAIN MENINGITIS HAD BROKEN
OUT IN ASIA, AND WE DID NOT WANT
TO HAVE TO ACCEPT THE GOODS FROM
IN ASIA.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP USED FOR THE
RIGHT PURPOSE, SO A JUDGE
DECIDED THAT TITLE 42 -- WE WERE
NOT USING IT FOR THE RIGHT
PURPOSES.
THINGS HAVE SUBSIDED WITH COVID.
LOUISIANA, LOUISIANA JUDGE SAID
THIS IS TITLE 42, HOW IT SHOULD
BE USED.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION -- I
THINK DANA HAS SETTLED ON THE
RIGHT POLITICAL POINT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE.
THEY CANNOT HIDE.
AND I HOPE THEY COME OUT ON THE
SIDE OF CONTINUING WITH TITLE 42
BECAUSE I AM NOT CONVINCED THAT
THE COMMUNICABLE DISEASE ISSUE
HAS NOT SUBSIDED TO THE POINT --
THE GOVERNORS WHO HAVE DONE
THIS, THEY ARE NOT AS WORRIED
ABOUT COVID.
THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A VIABLE,
SERIOUS IMMIGRATION POLICY.
IF I WERE REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS, THE FIRST THING THEY
SHOULD DO, SIMULTANEOUSLY, TO
PUT FORTH AN IMMIGRATION PLAN,
BORDER SECURITY PLAN.
I WILL SUPPORT YOU IF IT IS
REASONABLE, IF IT IS FAIR.
I THINK YOU WILL FIND A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE GOING TO WANT
TO DO THAT AS WELL BECAUSE YOU
NEED BOTH OF THESE THINGS.
EVEN IF THEY SAY TITLE 42 SHOULD
REMAIN, WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
A BORDER CHALLENGE UNTIL SOMEONE
ASKED.
REPUBLICANS WHO BELIEVE AS
STRONGLY AS THEY DO, FORCE
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE TO WORK
WITH YOU.
FORCE PRESIDENT BIDEN TO EITHER
SIGN SOMETHING OR VETO
SOMETHING.
THE COUNTRY NEEDS YOU GUYS TO BE
SERIOUS ON THIS.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
TITLE 41?
THE FEDERAL STATUTE -- JUST
THOUGHT I WOULD KEEP YOU ON
TRACK THERE.
TITLE 43.
DIDN'T WE JUST TALK ABOUT THAT?
TITLE 43 IS THE GOVERNMENT
CONSUMPT